kim kardashian west is headed to the
olympics or at least her clothes are
on monday kardashian west announced that
her shapewear and loungewear company
skims
is designing the official undergarments
for female members of team usa at the
2021 olympics
the olympic sleepwear and loungewear was
modeled monday by paralympian scout
bassett
track and field star delilah muhammad
soccer player alex morgan
and swimmer haley anderson the line will
be available to the public in july
just in time for the olympics opening
ceremony on july 23rd
kardashian west is not the only
billionaire with a hand in
outfitting this year's team ralph lauren
who is worth
seven billion dollars has designed team
usa's uniform since 2008
team usa will wear that clothing in both
the opening and
closing ceremonies in april skims had a
valuation of 1.6 billion dollars after
it raised 154 million dollars in a
combination of series a
and series 1a funding from investors
including thrive capital
alliance consumer growth and imaginary
ventures
[Music]
you